hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my agents of shield episode 4
Ghost Rider versus hellfire video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet so this is a great comic
book episode I feel like last week I
ended up not doing a video just because
they really didn't do a lot of comic
book stuff so it was more of like a
character based episode this is an
episode where they tease the Darkhold
they tease Mephisto again and they did
Hellfire vs. Ghost Rider the most comic
book thing you could think of early in
the season this is like something born
out of the pure joy of a little kid's
mind oh my god we have to fire based
characters what would it be like if they
faced off they both have a chain as
their main weapon in the comics even
though the Robby Reyes version of ghost
riders a little bit different so this is
going to be a little bit different I'm
just going to go through the episode
there's like so much stuff happening
today especially with the guardians of
the galaxy trailer dropping so just
going through the Easter eggs like big
comic book WTF moments we have the
resolution of the inhuman plot or almost
the resolution they just they find out
how it is they're getting all the names
of the Inhumans and it's because the
Hellfire character has turned on his own
kind like he views it all with contempt
like he just absolutely hates himself
hates everything that happened last
season it just feels like getting rid of
all the Inhumans will make those
problems go away so hilarious that he's
working in a fireworks store but I
always like the actors performance he
always added like a little something fun
to episodes I don't know how he's going
to fit into this season because it seems
like they're transitioning away from the
Inhumans on the TV show just so they can
double down on all this mystical dr.
strange Darkhold Mephisto Ghost Rider
stuff which I feel like is a smart move
for the show because there's not going
to be an Inhumans movie for a long time
they'll still do one but it's like a
long ways off it just makes sense that
they wouldn't focus on Inhumans until
that becomes a thing usually the TV show
this like connected Marvel Universe
between the TV shows and the movies
benefits from movies that are coming out
so they focus on Captain America stuff
when Captain America movies are coming
out they're focusing on mystical magic
stuff because Doctor Strange is coming
up so even though at Comic Con they said
that they would have access to some of
the classic inhuman care
now that's talking about like core in
human characters maybe royal family that
might not be till the second half of the
season in something for next year
because we have Ghost Rider this season
he's been great so far I love what
they've done with the character they
made some changes to his comic book
backstory that I'll explain in a second
but I am kind of worried that they're
gonna go through this Ghost Rider plot
this season and he just won't be a part
of season five like that's my fear I
really want them to keep Ghost Rider
around as long as possible
he's completely turned the show around
for me that's why it feels less exciting
when he's not on screen important stuff
though the dark hold everybody got
really excited when they mentioned I
think they named dropped it in either
last week or episode two but now they're
like fully doing it they show us a
picture of it in the episode they even
say Hydra tried to find it Nick Fury
tried to find it I liked all the name
drops like just all these big people in
the Marvel Universe that had been
searching for it but have been unable to
find it and normally you would think the
Doctor Strange would have it inside the
sanctum sanctorum but remember in the
MCU right now Stephen strange has not
become sorcerer supreme so once he does
he would be the person to show up take
the book and put it inside the sanctum
for safekeeping because the sanctum also
kind of works like Odin's vault it's a
repository for really dangerous magical
artifacts that dr. strange doesn't want
falling into the wrong hands so the way
they explain it in the episode is
actually pretty clear the dark hold is
basically a grimoire it's one of the
most powerful books of magic in the
Marvel Universe and surprise surprise it
was mostly featured in Doctor Strange
comics and there was even a run of Ghost
Rider comics so this is where they're
bringing it around the Ghost Rider
there's a run of Ghost Rider comics
called dark hold pages from the book of
sins it was a run that started in 1992
spinning out of rise of the midnight
suns which was a Ghost Rider storyline
so if you really like Ghost Rider and
you really like that early 90s art style
and you want to read the story you can
go search for that the name of the
storyline is called dark hold pages from
the book of sins it was basically like a
sixteen issue run so they'll probably be
some Easter eggs showing up from that
storyline but they always change the
comics just a little bit to fit with the
character
they're doing on the TV show so speaking
of which changes to Ghost Rider
backstory so if you read Robbie ray as
is run as Ghost Rider in the comics he's
like the most recent version of the
character in the comics the thing that
they changed is is that in the comics
his uncle is the spirit of vengeance
that he bonds with he doesn't sell his
soul to Mephisto like the other versions
of Ghost Rider and his uncle who's like
this really crazy murderer tries to take
over his consciousness so that he can
just murder as much as he wants he's
just a terrible person but what they've
done in the TV show so far like know
this could be a misdirect but it seems
like they're telling us that his uncle
is a good person like he's the only
person from his school that got a PhD he
clawed his way out of the gutter
so to speak so they're trying to make
his uncle seem really sympathetic you
know maybe that's because they don't
want him to be a super-duper stereotype
or something like that
but either way it's a change from the
comics meaning that what they might have
done like Ghost Rider keeps saying that
he sold his soul to the devil maybe he
actually did sell his soul to Mephisto
so just keep in mind that they changed
some of Robbie raises comic book
backstory
let me know in the comments what was
your favorite part of the episode like
what do you think about the life model
decoy storyline I feel like that's kind
of in a holding pattern right now like
they're still testing aid out she needs
to pass the Coulson test it seems like
she is but it is kind of funny that
Simmons figured it out immediately like
she knew instantly that ADA was
artificial intelligence so that means
that other people will also probably
figure it out pretty quickly but as you
can see Daisy and Ghost Rider are now
formally on the shield team you might
not need us but we need you so basically
like the family the band is back
together so to speak but it was a great
episode and I like the way they're
making like a hard left turn into Doctor
Strange territory like you kind of
expect the way they talk about this book
the power that has how dangerous it is
you just expect dr. strange to show up
and just take the book and say I'm
keeping this it just teleport back to
the sanctum with it here's the problem
with that though Doctor Strange is
coming out at the beginning of November
the mid-season finale for agents of
shield isn't going to be till December
meaning that if dr. strange eventually
does take possession
of the book that it probably won't be
too much much later
a really big Marvel stuff this week so
guardians trailer dropped this morning
obviously I've just posted that video
I'll probably do a follow up Guardians
video later this week there's a Deadpool
video that I want to make and there's an
arrow SummerSlam episode happening
tonight basically like a hardcore
wrestling match between Stephen Amell
and Cody Rhodes so that video will
probably post early tomorrow so just be
sure to subscribe to get everything
whole bunch of Marvel DC stuff happening
this week so just changing the outro a
little bit while you guys wait for that
next video to post you can click up top
for that guardians of the galaxy trailer
and you can click down here for all my
Doctor Strange videos thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight